Data science teams work in
diverse technical environments
with many data
sources, coding tools,
computational requirements
and client expectations
for data products.
Having this work spread
across multiple systems
creates inefficient work silos
and introduces critical gaps
in security.
RStudio Workbench
addresses all of this
by providing IT the
ability to manage and scale
data ingestion, analysis and
data product creation securely,
all from one place,
while providing
data scientists the ability
to collaborate on R and Python projects.
Whether RStudio,
with its ability
to run multiple versions of R
in different sessions or Jupyter Lab
or Jupyter
Notebooks or VS code,
each with the option of running
pre-configured data connectors,
requesting compute resources
and providing the ability
to collaborate within
a shared environment.
If they choose to use
the RStudio IDE, team members
can share projects and
track work in real time,
helping to keep up with changes
and supporting best practices
for code review, which
ultimately allows data science
leaders to build happy
and effective teams
while delivering value
to their stakeholders.
Using RStudio Workbench,
the data science team
can create reports, dashboards
and interactive applications
for their organizations
decision makers,
which can be hosted on
platforms such as RStudio Connect.
By moving work
from the local laptop
and onto RStudio Workbench,
users can quickly
authenticate and spin up
the coding environment of their
choice for either R or Python,
providing easy access
to pre-configured data connectors
like Snowflake,
MongoDB and Spark,
just to name a few.
Your team can also request
critical compute resources
that they won't likely have
access to on local systems
with different user or
group profiles for default
and max resource usage,
which helps to control cost.
RStudio Workbench
makes it easier
for teams to work together by
providing a standardized set
of installed software, which
helps ensure that data science work
is reproducible
between team members.
And integration with Git
supports collaboration and
code governance across
coding environments.
RStudio Workbench:
Enable your team,
to build great data
science products.